[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight quite a day in financial
markets not a phrase we use a lot on
this show but a lot happened today and
there are massive
implications for all of us dave portnoy
joins us in a moment to explain what
those are but first some context for
what we're watching right now
last march as the country began to panic
about the arrival of a strange new
coronavirus from china
a billionaire called bill ackman went on
television in an attempt to make america
even more afraid than it already was
our economy may be done at this point he
said
over dead not coming back bill ackman
went on like this
for 28 full minutes terrified cnbc
viewers watched slackjawed as he
ranted here's part of his performance
hell is coming this was a feeling like
i've never had
like there's a tsunami coming right the
tsunami's coming in you feel it in the
air
right the tide starts to roll out okay
and
on the beach people are playing and
having fun like there's nothing going on
and that is the feeling i've had for the
last two months
okay and my colleagues at work okay
thought i was a lunatic
we need to shut it down now america will
end as we know it okay i'm sorry to say
so
okay unless we take this option
bill ackman was afraid and he wanted you
to be afraid
ackman was especially frightened for the
future of hilton hotels
hilton hotel's akmin proclaim quote is
going to zero
along with every other hotel company in
the world every hotel is going to be
shut down
in the country every one talk about
scary
but in the end not for bill ackman not
long after that appearance we learned
that ackman's firm had made more than
two billion dollars from trading in the
stocks that many people believed
he had pushed down with the hysterically
dire predictions you just saw
including hilton hotels so was ackman's
rant on cnbc
part of a very dishonest investment
strategy
seemed pretty obvious so we said so on
the air ackman's lawyers immediately
threatened to sue us
in a long phone conversation later
ackman swore to us that his public
attack on hilton hotels
had nothing at all to do with his desire
to buy hotel stocks
at a lower price or with the billions in
profit that his firm subsequently
reported
there was no connection whatsoever he
promised and he sounded emotional as he
said it
we'll let you assess bill ackman's
sincerity we do know that this kind of
behavior is common on wall street
ackman himself once attacked the company
herbalife on television
it's going to zero he once again
predicted in an effort to profit from
herbalife's decline
pretty ugly but that kind of thing
happens a lot on wall street
hedge fund managers bet money that a
specific stock will decline in value
that's called short selling
short selling has no obvious value to
the american economy
short selling exists for the purpose of
enriching the people who do it
short selling hurts companies obviously
it hurts their investors
hurts their employees ultimately it
hurts our country itself
yet it continues no one does anything
about short selling
regulators ignore it cnbc applauds the
brilliance of the people who do it
oh they're so clever those hedge fund
managers in fact
nbc's business channel regularly lends
its airwaves to unscrupulous short
sellers
who use free tv airtime you may have
seen this
to tank american companies for profit
they do that all the time the last
administration did nothing to stop this
the current administration certainly
won't the biden white house is more
tightly controlled by business interests
than any administration in history
virtually every person there
is beholden to the finance establishment
what's happening on wall street is so
clearly awful and so obviously
destructive the question is
who's going to fight back against it as
it turns out a bunch of guys on reddit
will
it fell to them to push back against the
short sellers because no one else even
tried
so they did a group of independent
investors in a reddit group called wall
street bets
learned that hedge funds plan to short
the stock of a fading retail company
called gamestock
so the reddit investors began buying
shares of gamestop
and gain stop surged in value ultimately
up by more than a thousand percent
the hedge funds for all their
calculation hadn't seen that coming
and they lost billions as a result of it
one hedge fund lost so much money it
needed a bailout from two other hedge
funds
meanwhile some of the investors on
reddit got rich
but getting rich was not the whole
reason they did it
they also wanted to send a message to
the hedge fund managers
here's one of the reddick guys a man
called justin speak
explaining i'd be lying to say if
there wasn't some pleasure out of the
fact you know i'm a pastor and jesus
tells a story about this rich fool
who has an over abundant harvest that's
more than he can store
and rather than give the excess to those
in needs he chooses to build bigger and
bigger barns to store it for himself
and rather than share the billions with
the less fortunate they've built bigger
and bigger barns for themselves and so
yeah i was 100 there was a part of me
that thought well it will be fun to be a
part of this moment to see this moment
where
at some level overnight these investors
are losing their investing lives it's
being demanded from them
and they're left wondering what what
they get what who's going to get what
they had prepared for themselves
they've built bigger barns for
themselves well that's
true not to mention epically enormous
art collections the hedge fund people in
case you haven't noticed in case you
don't read the business press
are very proud of their art collections
very aggressively flamboyantly proud
despite the fact that a lot of their
so-called art
is ugly overpriced garbage cheap garish
crap
that people will laugh at a generation
from now and that tells you a lot
it turns out that a lot of our financial
wizards have awful taste
they're as vulgar as the way they do
business they don't know that though
because no one dares tell them
in a country that worships finance
people
the other kind of rich people who still
think frank gehry is a brilliant
architect not a scam artist
so people like that arrogant lacking any
self-awareness whatsoever
understandably generate some resentment
from the rest of the population
they pause and say wait a second bill
ackman and the many people on wall
street who behave like bill ackman
what exactly did you do to make two
billion dollars
did you improve anything was it just
another sleazy inside deal that the rest
of us were excluded from participating
in
tell us now please speak solely so we
can understand your answer
that was pretty much the message the
reddit guys were sending to wall street
watching at home a lot of americans
applauded that message
they feel the same way but the hedge
fund people don't they weren't happy
people who lose money really are happy
but here's what make the
hedge fund managers different from you
they have a lot more power than you
they control the game so they
immediately change the rules of the game
today the investment app robin hood
which is used by independent investors
to buy and sell stock
banned its users from trading game stock
shares
as well as from several other company
shares no one even knew that was
legal maybe it isn't but robin hood did
it anyway and they did it under pressure
from the hedge funds who they really
work for
so much for the free market you're
always hearing about there's something
free about it
that turned out to be a lie turns out
that what wall street really hates is
outsider trading the idea that people
from outside their world
might be getting rich that's the one sin
they can't abide
the management of robin hood of course
didn't admit any of this they can't
they're still posing instead as an
outpost of inclusive progressive values
in a sea of rapacious capitalism the
irony being of course
robin hood is the most rapacious they
sell
information they gather from their
customers to the hedge funds
who use it for their advantage and most
customers don't even know
how's that for progressive on the other
hand they do support blm
they're against hate and systemic racism
they're for science
and they want you to know that here's an
ad from robin hood that ran just last
month
remember when greed was good when you
had to look the part
when you had to pay for a seat at the
table we set out to change it
the way the system works to put the
power in
everyone's hands to make it feel speak
sound and look just like you we all
invest every day in ourselves our
communities
our future we are all investors
[Music]
it's so fun to watch that stuff after
the fact
that ran a month ago we set out to
change the way the system works says
robin hood
well that's for sure in fact that's
literally true robin hood changed the
system
at precisely the moment when people from
outside the system started benefiting
from the system
sorry proles no trading for you were
locking your account
other platforms took effectively the
same position but felt the need to
pretend a little more than robin hood
did
they justify changing the rules by
attacking the very people they were
hurting by changing the rules
the communications service discord for
example
banned users from the wall street bets
group for using its platform why'd they
do that
it wasn't all because the reddit guys
were beating the hedge fund guys with
their own grubby game and that's not
allowed no it had nothing to do with
that of course
no instead they were banned according to
discord because the reddit guys had
engaged in quote
hate speech of course the reddit guys
were racists
that's when he humiliated the hedge
funds only a racist would do that
you can laugh if you want but keep in
mind this is a
time tested tactic it works that's why
they do it
remember back if you can to the occupy
wall street protests of more than a
decade ago
the 2008 crash wrecked an awful lot of
families in this country many have not
recovered even now
people are angry about that and many
blamed wall street and they said so
but rather than address their grievances
some of them legitimate
wall street and its countless puppets in
the media just changed the subject
so it was right about this point that we
started hearing an
awful lot about identity politics
we can prove that in 2011 when the
occupy movement was at its peak
mentions of the word racism in the new
york times the washington post and los
angeles times
skyrocketed in the case of the
washington post which is america's most
committed defender of entrenched power
literally owned now by the richest man
in the world mentions of
racism nearly tripled at the height of
occupy wall street
oh and of course it worked they changed
the subject they're doing that again
they always do that
always over on cnbc home of the
professional short seller the ones who
tell you to sell
when they profit from it they haven't
started yet yelling about the scourge of
white supremacy on reddit though
obviously that's coming it's inevitable
but they started their defense at big
finance a little more tactfully than
that
the problem with humiliating hedge funds
explained to anchor and professional
hedge fund shill and
ross sorkin is that in the end
humiliating hedge funds
only hurts the people who do it so for
their own good
they might want to stop this nonsense
immediately what i'm concerned about is
that this is a pump and dump scheme
that effectively is being cloaked uh you
know as mother teresa has arrived
on the scene i think there are real
underlying issues with the system
that need to be resolved i do not want
to protect the system
i i i love watching the little guy beat
the big guy
as much as anybody but what i wonder is
whether
uh these folks trying to quote stick it
to the man are ultimately going to be
sticking it
to themselves they only hurt themselves
with their scheme not at all like what
the guests on this channel do this is a
scheme
and andrew ross sorkin is deeply
concerned about this scheme he's just
really really worried
that average people might be hurt by
this scheme he can barely sleep thinking
about it he was so
fraught with anxiety last night he was
almost late to soul cycle this morning
that's how much he tossed and turned
beneath his goose down duvet as he
pondered the fate
of america's beleaguered middle class
which is hilarious
but even if you were to believe it it's
a little late honestly
where was andrew ross sorkin for the
last dozen years
as the central bank shoveled trillions
to wall street
thereby enriching a few devaluing the
american dollar
guaranteeing hyperinflation and of
course destroying the value of the
average person's savings
did indra sorkin even notice that any of
that happened the reddit guys noticed
that's why they're mad jenny ellen might
have something interesting to say about
all of this jenny ellen ran the federal
reserve for years beginning under barack
obama
as much as any single person on earth
janet yellen is responsible for creating
the distorted financial system
that made the reddit revolt possible
indeed inevitable
so where is janet yellen now and what
does she have to say for herself oh yeah
as of last week
janet yellen is joe biden's treasury
secretary here's what joe biden's flack
had to say yesterday about jenny ellen
the white house concerned about the
stock market activity we're seeing
around game stop
and now with some other stocks as well
uh including
the subsidiary or whatever the company
that was uh blockbuster
um and have there been any conversations
with the sec about
uh how to proceed well um i'm also
happy to repeat that we have the first
female treasury secretary and a team
that's surrounding her and
often questions about market we'll send
to them but our team is of course our
economic team including
secretary yellen and others are
monitoring the situation it's a good
reminder though that the stock market
isn't the only measure of the health of
our econo
our economy it doesn't reflect how
working and middle class families are
doing
so as her first answer gensake is quote
happy to repeat that janet yellen is the
first female treasury secretary let's
translate
actually jenny allen has nothing to say
about reddit or gamestock
or short selling or even the dangerously
corrupt condition of american finance
more broadly she hasn't thought about
those things
probably doesn't even care jenny yellen
herself has made millions from hedge
funds
including from funds that lost money to
the reddit guys
but whatever buzz off we'd like to
remind you that jenny allen is a woman
and so are many of the people around her
these brave leaders have broken glass
ceilings they are empowered
and that's enough we can't give you an
answer we won't improve your life
but we do have diversity so you should
be happy
that's their position has there ever
been in all human history
a clearer distillation of the essence of
neoliberalism
than that probably there never has been
maybe at this point people will start to
catch on to the game
suddenly people are catching on to a lot
of things it looks like
looking back we may see the reddit guys
and their
effective defense of gamestop as a kind
of turning point in this country's
history
whatever our current system is it is
definitely not the capitalism we were
promised
not even close one of the rare people in
media who understands this is our next
guest
he's the founder of barstool sports as
well as an independent investor who
trades an awful lot online and has done
well
dave portnoy joins us now to explain
exactly what this moment means
dave this kind of gets to the heart of
what you've been doing under
quarantine and i'm wondering what
lessons we can draw from this what is
happening
exactly you know
i've been trading heavily since
quarantine started and i was shocked by
this uh i personally did invest in
amc and nokia those are two of the
stocks that
the reddick guys and the wall street
bets guys were pushing i believed in the
power of the internet
when i saw what uh robin hood was doing
ironically robin hood take from you know
take from the rich and give to the poor
even though they do the exact opposite
i was stunned uh i think it's criminal i
think there has to be an investigation i
think people have to go to jail
whether that actually happens i don't
know but i've never been more convinced
about market manipulation and the people
the hedge funds
controlling the game than today i
i mean just to wake up and say hey you
can't trade these stocks anymore you can
only sell them
we're going to intentionally crash the
market in these stocks
and everyone who has it tough you're
going to lose a ton of money
but we're going to save the rich people
in the hedge funds
shocking like in 20 years of me doing
barstool i'm not exaggerating
it's the most shocked i've been and
maybe i shouldn't be
but you know when you have aoc
and donald trump jr both on the same
side of an issue
you know something's dramatically wrong
this seems like a betrayal of the basic
promise of
american public markets which is their
transparency purely meritocratic if you
i mean that's why you've been able to
make dough during quarantine
you make a bet you're right you win i
mean how amazing is it to discover that
that's not real
apparently it's real for them and i love
the lectures you hear it from the hedge
funds and the suits as i call them
but they'll say they're protecting you
and we're protecting you first yourself
and people don't understand the risk and
margin
and then you look at him it's like buddy
look in the mirror
you're doing the same thing the hedge
funds are betting against companies
we're betting on them with money and
margin we're doing the same thing the
only difference is we're winning
and you're getting your teeth kicked in
and you just said
time out we're changing the rules and
it's bananas
it it cannot happen and i saw the robin
hood
guy vlad he's on tv he's lying through
his teeth there is
listen the thing that really is scary
robin hood
i'm going to give this guy a shred of
credit when he woke up and he said we're
going to halt trading
and ruin our mo our client base he knew
that was the end of robin hood
robin is done that company will cease to
exist because what they built it on
the day trader the retail trader they're
never going back
so he willingly blew up his company
today
he knew that was gonna happen why who's
in the back end
who's pulling the strings who's making
the decisions we have to find out
and by the way it's not enough just to
be like oh we're gonna slap you on the
wrist and give you a fine
these are billionaires they can write
billion dollar checks like we write 10
checks somebody has to go to jail for
this this is intentional
market manipulation and it's everyday
people's just not the reddit people
i have people hit me up all the time
today yesterday
they're putting their rent into this
they got caught up in the momentum
and if you lose money fair and square
fine but nobody was under the impression
somebody could just press the stop
button and say
guess what we can crash this stock
without you having any say you can only
sell it you can't buy it
what happened this is like the movie
wall street it's insane
i just read a piece about 15 minutes ago
that said
and it seemed right that robin hood's
real customer
is not retail investors like you it's
real customer is the hedge funds
they sell data on trades to the hedge
funds which use it to their advantage
assuming that's true did you know that
well do you think anyway robin hood knew
that i didn't know that
i did not know that till today i don't
think anybody knew a lot of the things
that were going on till today
um you know again robin hood was
operating under
the guys that this was a retail trading
platform
a lot of people said i helped build it
because we had all our retail bros as
they call them going there
they literally in their bio said they're
going to democracize trading
it's the exact opposite and now they're
saying we're going to go back to normal
tomorrow we're going to let everybody do
our normal trading tomorrow well tucker
what changed oh i'll tell you what
changed
the billionaire hedge funds they got out
of their shorts tonight
so what why is this uh behavior not
risky tomorrow but it was today
it's because they're being pulled by
strings it's criminal behavior what
happened today
plain and simple people have to go to
jail plain and simple
best description i've heard i got to ask
you before you go several weeks ago you
announced you were starting this fund
to help businesses a lot of restaurants
that were hurt by the corona shutdowns
you're starting to raise money
how much did you raise and how's it
going
it we are closing in on 33 million
dollars raised
over 200 businesses we've helped we have
over 200 000 people have donated to it
and it's uh you know again i'm a prickly
guy but it's been
it's been gratifying to be able to help
and thank you to everybody who's donated
we continue to do it
but we're helping a lot of small
businesses and a lot of employees in a
lot of communities so it actually
it's been it's been great it really has
it's amazing
you're like your own federal agency at
this point helping people when others
won't i appreciate it dave portney thank
you for coming on tonight
thanks tucker